ACCORDING TO MY RUNDOWN IS
"THE FIVE" ."
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LASER FOCUS ON
CRACKING DOWN ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, I'M SURE THAT YOU
AMERICA SAFE AGAIN.
IN FACT QUOTA CROSSINGS ARE
DOWN, BUT THE NEW REPORT
SUGGESTS HE SENT FEWER MEXICANS
BACK TO THEIR COUNTRY BETWEEN
IT'S WORKING HARD AT KEEPING
MEXICANS FROM CROSSING OVER
LEGALLY IN THE FIRST PLACE, HE
HINTED LAST WEEK HE WILL MAKE A
TRIP TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER OVER
TO SAN DIEGO LOOKING AT THE TYPE
OR HIS PROPOSED MALL, NOW MAKING
AND THEN WE WILL SEE IF THEY DO
SOMETHING BELOW, BECAUSE WE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF A TUNNEL
>> ALSO FEWER ILLEGAL BORDER
GOOD MARKETING WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN THAT
FEWER PEOPLE CAME INTO THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, AND ALSO IT
SHOWS THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS A
MUCH BIGGER HEART THAN
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO IS
ABSOLUTELY AWFUL ABOUT
SUPPORTING PEOPLE AND RIPPING
FAMILIES APART AND IT IS
LAUGHABLE THAT HE REACHED OUT TO
THE LATINO COMMUNITY THE WAY
THAT HE DID, BECAUSE HE
WAS INCREDIBLY HEARTLESS WITH
HIS DEPORTATION, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ACTUALLY
SOFTEN AND LOOKING FOR OTHER
WAYS TO TRY TO SOLVE THE
IMMIGRATION CRISIS.
>> MARIE, IT TURNS OUT THAT I DO
CHANCE TO GO TO THE BORDER TWO
WEEKS AGO, AND THEY THINK THAT
THE BEGINNING OF THE WALL WILL
BE BUILT IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY SECTOR WHERE IT IS THE
WORST.
BUT THE WORD CAME OUT IN THE
FIRST HALF OF THE YEAR THAT WE
YEAR WHEN WE DID NOT DO ANYTHING
POLICY WISE BECAUSE CONGRESS
COULD NOT GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER, IT PICKED UP AGAIN AND
THEN YOU HAVE THESE NUMBERS
OVERALL, WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU?
>> WE WILL SEE HOW BIG
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HEART IS WHEN
WE DEAL WITH DACA AND THE NEW
YEAR, THAT IS THE BIGGEST
IMMIGRATION FIGHT THAT WE WILL H
IMMIGRATION FIGHT THAT WE WILL V
IMMIGRATION FIGHT THAT WE WILL E
IMMIGRATION FIGHT THAT WE WILL R
IMMIGRATION FIGHT THAT WE WILL Y
IMMIGRATION FIGHT THAT WE WILL O
IMMIGRATION FIGHT THAT WE WILL .
THE NUMBERS ARE INTERESTING, I'M
NOT SURE WHAT TO MAKE OF THEM
COME I THINK THAT FEWER PEOPLE
ARE COMING HERE, THEY HAVE
ARRESTED MORE IMMIGRANTS, BUT
THEY HAVE SUPPORTED FEWER BACK
WILL BE ABLE TO BUILD A WALL
CAN PUT UP THE STRUCTURE, TAKE A
PHOTO WITH IT, SAY THAT HE HAS
KEPT HIS PROMISE, BECAUSE IN
MUCH DO NOT WANT THE GOVERNMENT
COMING IN AND SOME OF THESE
IT IS GOING TO BE AN EMINENT
DOMAIN BATTLE, BUT I DO NOT
THINK THAT EVERYBODY IS FOCUSED
ON THAT.
>> WHY WOULD THEY WANT A WALL?
>> THEY DON'T WANT ILLEGAL
CROSSINGS ON THE PROPERTY,
RIGHT?
>> TEXAS ESPECIALLY, THIS IS AN
ISSUE BECAUSE THERE ARE FAMILIES
THAT WERE PROPERTY OWNERS BEFORE
TEXAS WAS A STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, SO THE
CULTURE IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN DEALING WITH THE
OR BORDER PATROL TO BE ON THEIR
PROPERTY, WORKING WITH BORDER
PATROL TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE NOT CROSSING BACK AND FORTH,
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT THEY
WANT THEIR RANCHES DIVIDED BY A
BIG WALL.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A BIG
BATTLE THERE.
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS, NOT ALL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE MEXICANS, ONLY 50%
ONE OF THE BIG REASONS WE HAVE
IS THE OVERSTAY, 54 MILLION
PEOPLE THAT COME INTO THE
COUNTRY EVERY YEAR, 7000 OF THEM
STAY BEHIND, INTERIOR
ENFORCEMENT IS AN ISSUE COMING
IN UNDER OBAMA HE WAS CALLED THE
DEPORT OR IN CHIEF, BUT THE WAY
BORDER AND IMMEDIATELY DEPORT
THEM, THEY COUNTED THAT AS A
DEPORTATION, THAT IS NOT GOING
IN THE COMMUNITY AND REVVING
PEOPLE UP AND DEPORTING THEM,
THEY WERE COUNTING PEOPLE
TURNING THEMSELVES INTO BORDER
PATROL AND GETTING KICKED OUT AS
A DEPORTATION, THAT'S WHY THE
NUMBER WAS SO HIGH.
>> THAT IS A GREAT POINTS COMING
IN ONE THING IS ALSO CLEAR, IT
IS NOT JUST MEXICANS,
CENTRAL AMERICA AND
SOUTH AMERICA THE WAY THAT THE
BORDER IS COMING YOU CAN KEEP
GOING, YOU CAN COME IN AS LONG
AS YOU WANT TO.
KEEP GOING, SO IT IS REALLY NOT
MEXICO RIGHT NOW THAT IT IS A
PROBLEM, THAT IS AMONG THE
BORDER PATROL, BUT KEEP IN MIND
THE FEAR OF DRUGS, NO COMING
ACROSS THE THE SOUTHERN BORDER
IS A PROBLEM.
>> FEWER PEOPLE DEPORTED SHOULD
BE CELEBRATED, THE HEADLINES IN
THE PAPER THAT TRUMP SENDS FEWER
AND THEN IT SAYS RHETORIC VERSUS
REALITY.
>> JUST TALKING ABOUT
DEPORTATION, THE FACT THAT IT IS
EMPTY TALK, BUT IT IS NOT.
IF YOU'RE TOUGH TALK MAKES FEWER
PEOPLE COME ACROSS THE BORDER IT
SHOULD BE TRUMPED IMMIGRATION
POLICY WORKING.
>> THE OTHER THING THAT THEY ARE
TO TALK ABOUT IMMIGRATION AND
THERE IS A BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE
IN THE SENATE RIGHT NOW THAT HIS
PASSING CHAIN MIGRATION BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THE SENTIMENT ON BOTH
SIDES TO ATTACK ADS, THE LOTTERY
AS WELL AND DACA TO MIXING WITH
BORDER SECURITY, COULD THIS BE
THE FIRST JOINT LEGISLATORS
SINCE THE 20s?
>> IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
PEOPLE'S FEELINGS ABOUT
IMMIGRATION EVOLVES WITH SOME OF
THE FACTS AND REALITY AND NEWS
THAT HAPPENS, AND WHETHER IT IS
KATE STEINLE'S DEATH, WHICH WAS
CAPITALIZED ON THE RIGHTS OR
SOME OF THE TERROR INCIDENTS HAD
TO REACH ACROSS PARTY LINES AND
PEOPLE GO, WELL, I'M WONDERING
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN MY
WELL, STILL ATTRACTING FAMOUS
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD TO COME AND
WORK AT BUSINESSES AND HELP TAKE
CARE OF FAMILIES AND
PARTICIPATES IN THE ECONOMY, I
MEAN, THAT IS WHAT YOU WANT TO.
SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW DO WE
FIX IMMIGRATION TO KEEP BAD
PEOPLE OUT WITHOUT COMPROMISING
THE CIVIL LIBERTY.
THAT IS A BIG GOAL, THE ULTIMATE
GOAL, BUT I THINK REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS ARE MUCH CLOSER ON
THAT, BECAUSE PEOPLE ESSENTIALLY
WANT THE SAME THING.
THEY WANT THE COUNTRY TO BE
SAFE.
IF THEY WANT THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST PEOPLE HERE, AND THEY
REALIZE THAT THE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN ON SEVERAL ENDS, VISA AND
IT BE SO OVER STATE, WE HAVE TO
FIX THE VISA SYSTEM AND
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO LIVE UP TO THE
PROMISES THAT THEY MADE ON
BORDER SECURITY 11 YEARS AGO.
>> Brian: MARIE, TELL ME WHERE
THE NO-GO ZONE IS, I'VE NOT SEEN
IT YET EXCEPT FOR BUILD A WALL,
DOES NOT WANT TO GIVE HIM THE
VICTORY, I HAVE NOT HEARD HIM
AFFECT THE CHAIN MIGRATION AND
THE LOTTERY SYSTEM BEING
RE-EXAMINED AND DACA OF COURSE
HE IS SAYING, I'M INTERESTED IN
GETTING THIS DONE COME MARCH, DO
YOU THINK THAT IT MIGHT BE
TWO-THIRDS OF THE WAY THERE, OR
AM I DREAMING?
>> Marie: YOU ARE WIDE-AWAKE,
YOU ARE NOT DREAMING, I THINK
THAT WE MIGHT BE CLOSE, IT WAS
TWEETED THAT THERE WILL BE A
DOCK OF A BIPARTISAN BILL TO THE
FLOOR AFTER THE NEW YEAR.
I THINK THAT THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT HE GOT IN EXCHANGE AS BEING
A "YES" ON TAX REFORM,
CHUCK SCHUMER WAS A PART OF THE
END OF CHAIN MIGRATION, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
ABSOLUTELY OPENING TO TALK
ABOUT.
THAT IS THE PACKAGE EARLIER IN
THE NEW YEAR, THE CLOSER YOU GET
TO NOVEMBER, THE HARDER IT
>> Katie: IF YOU ARE ABLE TO
TACKLE DACA AND THE DREAMERS,
TAKING CARE OF THINGS LIKE CHAIN
MIGRATION AND THE LOTTERY
SYSTEM, AND YOU DO NOT HOLD
AMNESTY INTO IT.
WILL BE A REALLY BIG CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE THE DETAILS OF DACA'S
ARE GOING TO BE HARD TO WORK
OUT, WHAT IS THE THRESHOLD IN
TERMS OF THE TIMING THAT WAS
BROUGHT HERE, DO YOU GET TO
STAY?
66% OF THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN
THE COUNTRY HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
MORE THAN TEN YEARS, WHICH MEANS
THE REST HAVE ONLY BEEN HERE FOR
FIVE, THAT IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT WILL BE LOOKING FOR SOME
FORM OF AMNESTY AND DOES INVOLVE
THE QUESTION OF WHAT DO WE DO
WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE,
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT ALL
DREAMERS, AND LET'S NOT FORGET
THAT BARACK OBAMA'S DREAMER
CRISIS, AND THAT IS A POTENTIAL
TO HAPPEN AGAIN IF THEY ARE NOT
CAREFUL ABOUT THE WAY THAT THEY
DEBATE THE LEGISLATION.
>> Brian: TOM, YOU ARE IN A
TOUGH SPOT, YOU ARE GOING TO USE
TO MIGRATION AND COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
SPEAK TO A FAIR STATE, TOM.
>> Tom: WE ARE JUST FINE,
BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE MERIT.
>> Brian: YOU BRING SOMETHING
TO THE TABLE?
>> Tom: WE DO NOT NEED TO
MIGRATION.
THEY CAN COME HERE BECAUSE THEY
ARE HIGHLY SKILLED.
A TRIPLE THREAT.
>> Tom: THIS IS THE ONE THING
I FEAR, WE ARE ALL TIRED OF
THIS, CONSERVATIVES WILL SAY,
YOU HAVE TO GET A DEAL ON
DACA, AND DEMOCRATS SAY YOU
CANNOT DO A DEAL WHICH FROM, WE
HAVE THE REPUBLICANS ON THEIR
BACK.
IF YOU LET TRUMP STAND UP AND
LOOK LIKE A CONSOLIDATOR, THERE
GOES THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
>> Marie: WE ARE CONFIDENT
ENOUGH IN WHAT WE ARE RUNNING
ON, AND TO KENNEDY'S POINT, THE
FACT THAT SO MANY REPUBLICANS
HAVE COME OUT IN SUPPORT OF DACA
AND GETTING IT FIXED AND DONE IS
GOOD.
NOT ALONE, BUT IT IS SUCH A
CHANGE FROM WHERE WE WERE A YEAR
AGO, TWO YEARS AGO, THREE YEARS
AGO, THAT'S WHY IT'S GOING TO
GET DONE.
TO THE 800,000 DREAMERS, I DO
BELIEVE BOTH SIDES OF THE I WANT
TO FIND A COMPROMISE.
>> Katie: CANNOT JUST SAY THAT
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
IN THIS COUNTRY IS SEVERELY
BROKEN.
LEGAL.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IT IS UNFAIR
THAT WE ARE FOCUSING ON THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION REFORM OF
THIS PROBLEM BEFORE WE ARE
FOCUSING ON THE LEGAL REFORM,
BECAUSE PEOPLE WAIT FIVE, TEN,
15 YEARS TO COME TO THE COUNTRY
LEGALLY AND PAY THOUSANDS OF
IMMIGRANTS ARE PAYING FOR DACA
AND THE DREAMERS THAT WERE HERE
BEFORE.
THAT'S HOW HE GOT AWAY WITH
DOING IT AND NOT GOING THROUGH
CONGRESS.
SO I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
AGREE ON, BUT THERE ARE BIGGER
IMMIGRATION PROBLEMS PUTTING
AMERICANS FIRST THAT THE
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN ON THAT
SHOULD BE KEPT FIRST.
>> Brian: I AM A PART OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT PRIDES ITSELF ON
INTERNATIONALS, THEY ARE ANGRY
AT THE WHOLE TALK OF DACA,
BECAUSE THEY GO THROUGH THE
WAIT ABOUT -- WHAT ABOUT US?
>> Kennedy: I GIVE PEOPLE
CREDIT FOR HAVING A NUANCED
CONVERSATION ABOUT IMMIGRATION,
BECAUSE THEY REALIZE THAT IT IS
HEARTLESS TO DEPORT PEOPLE IF
THIS IS THE ONLY HOME THAT THEY
DREAMERS.
AT THE SAME TIME, HAVING SAID
THAT, THEN YOU DO NOT CREATE THE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, AND I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU SHUT DOWN THE
NUMBER OF VISAS COME I THINK
THAT YOU DO A BETTER JOB OF
LETTING PEOPLE AND ALLOWING
PEOPLE IN WHO ARE GOING TO WORK
HARD.
WHAT IS THE METRIC FOR THAT, HOW
DO YOU MEASURE THAT?
I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY HAS THE ANSWER.
>> Katie: THIS IS ANOTHER BIG
QUESTION, YOU LOOK AT DACA IN
THE DREAMERS, TALK ABOUT NOT
BREAKING UP FAMILIES, GUESS
WHAT, DREAMERS ALL FAMILIES, IF
THEIR PARENTS ARE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, WHICH MANY OF THEM
ARE, BECAUSE I.C.E. DELIVERED
WHAT IS THEIR STATUS?
THAT IS A TOUGH QUESTION, YOU
CAN ARGUE IF YOU PASS THROUGH
DACA, THE ENTIRE FAMILY GETS TO
STAY BECAUSE WE ARE NOT A
HEARTLESS COUNTRY THAT THE PORTS
AND BREAKS UP FAMILIES, AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT IS DIFFICULT
TO DEAL WITH.
THAT IS AMNESTY FOR EVERYBODY.
>> Brian: DO YOU GUYS SEE WHAT
I AM DOING RIGHT HERE?
I AM CROSSING OUT THE A BLOCK.